tonight all is not well at the white
house
inflation record levels businesses they
can't find employees
more lockdowns are now imminent even
supported by the administration
a southern border well that's an
unmitigated disaster
violent crime is rising in almost every
major city in this country
russia is hacking critical supply lines
each and every month
china is openly now threatening the
united states
our military and our allies iran is back
to enriching uranium at an alarming rate
and the withdrawal from afghanistan is a
poorly planned debacle now we're leaving
behind
tons of arms and munitions for the
taliban
now this administration is unraveling
far faster
than we even expected and worst of all
no one knows
who is in charge as we told you earlier
in the week 57 percent now of americans
they see what we've been talking about
and few others have
and that is and by the way 58 percent of
independents even
a third of democrats see it and so does
america's enemies
the one thing that most agree on it's
definitely not
joe biden running the show and today yet
again he struggled to get words out
during his one
and only publicly scheduled event such a
tough schedule he has take a look
we went for two reasons one
to
bring osama bin laden to the
gates of hell as i said at the time
the second reason was to eliminate
al-qaeda's capacity to deal with more
attacks in the united states from that
territory
we accomplished both of those objectives
period just keep counting one one
thousand two one thousand three one
thousand four one thousand maybe when
you get to ten one thousand joe will
speak
and by the way joe you oppose the raid
to get bin laden
as i said earlier this week i honestly
can no longer laugh
i can't joke about biden's cognitive
struggles
everyone can see he is in really bad
shape our allies see it our enemies see
it the majority now the american people
they're seeing it
and it's downright dangerous now things
are so bad joe needs the help of no
cards
even after briefings with his staff less
than an
hour prior now joe's not calling the
shots he's not making decisions
instead it appears that he's just trying
to barely
barely get through that one scheduled
event a day
it is pathetic and here's the next
obvious question
who is making the decisions and who knew
what
and who knew what when about joe's
condition
for reference let's take a look at joe
biden this is from 2012
you'll notice two things in this
upcoming clip one
joe biden brags about being against the
bin
laden raid uh that took out the world's
worst terrorists
and two joe biden was well let's
put it charitably in a completely
different cognitive state
in 2012 than he is today you decide
he said i have to make decision what is
your opinion
he started the national security advisor
the secretary of state
and he ended with me every single person
in that room had their bed except leon
panetta
leon said go everyone else said
49 51 this got to me he said joe
what do you think and i said you know i
didn't know we had so many economists
around the table
i said we owe the man a direct answer mr
president my suggestion is don't go
my suggestion is don't go that joe biden
by the way
uh is long gone today's weak frail
cognitively struggling biden is getting
steamrolled by america's enemies this
week alone
we showed you china's hostile rhetoric
and violent threats
against american and japanese military
bases
china now openly talking about
reunification with taiwan warning of
dire military consequences if america
dares to help
our ally now we covered many in the
latest cyber attacks from russia
we covered iran's new uranium enrichment
program
we showed you how russia and china they
have now
aligned themselves and teamed up to
supply the iranians so they can fight
their proxy wars
all over the world the number one state
sponsor of terror
clearly none of these hostile actors
fear or respect joe biden
neither does the taliban as america
withdraws now
forces from afghanistan we have taliban
extremists they are moving in and moving
in quickly
and now we see that they're seizing u.s
weapons and supplies
in the process and then the question is
why
on earth would we ever leave munitions
weaponry behind like this knowing the
taliban would get a hold of it that is
simply
madness they know there will be no
consequences for their actions under
this administration
it's so bad that today biden was even
asked
if he trusts the taliban take a look
mr president you trust the television
are you
is that a serious question it's
absolutely a serious question you trust
the taliban
no i do not give the country to the
taliban no i do not trust
the taliban
mr president will you amplify that
question please will you amplify your
answer please while you don't consider
it
it's a silly question do i trust the
taliban no
then why did you leave the weaponry
behind believe it or not
the press secretary gensake the
messaging today on afghanistan that was
even worse than him
and she said there would be no
celebration for the troops coming home
because the war had not been won
militarily okay take a look
in terms of plans uh for the end uh for
our men and women uh coming back
i don't have anything to preview but we
don't we're not going to have a mission
accomplished moment in this regard it's
a
20-year war that has not been won
militarily
if the war was lost jen there's only one
reason and it's a political one
blame joe your boss and company
militarily the brave men the brave women
that fought
in afghanistan and decimated al qaeda
and heroically fought to maintain order
in a
failed state for two decades gensake
can't be bothered
to take the time to give them the
appropriate credit
tour after tour after tour that these
men served these women served
i wonder you know how how does this make
the families of
soldiers that died in afghanistan feel
tonight
jen you might need to circle back and do
something called
an apology at the very least the biden
administration
has now botched totally completely
botched
the withdrawal from afghanistan just
like they're botching america's economic
and political response to covid
and under biden the u.s is now printing
money faster than at any point in
history
and as a result that's called inflation
it's running through the roof
that's causing rising prices massive
shortages
a massive financial burden on every
single american
now thanks to joe's new green deal the
cost of a gallon of gasoline is now
at three dollars and above in most
places even
five dollars and higher in places like
california
nearly double what it was under donald
trump great job joe
the cost to heat and cool your home
that's also going through the roof
the cost for goods and services that's
costing more
that is being passed on to you as well
now there's a nationwide shortage of
even patio furniture just added to the
list
of shortages under biden that would be
oh beef shortages
chicken wings lumber gas and don't
forget the historic shortage of workers
and thanks to the administration's
generous never-ending
shutdowns that are draconian and their
handouts
employers cannot find workers anywhere
there are right now 9.2 million
job openings in the united states that
would be an all-time
high the restaurant industry as if they
weren't hurt enough during the draconian
shutdowns
they're probably suffering the most
according to one report a third of the
industry's workers
they're refusing to return to work large
cities are also having a hard time
hiring police
oh shocker after local national
democrats
have spent more than a year vilifying
the police
and stripped their budgets deep funding
dismantling reimagining
law enforcement many police departments
are
operating now reduced capacity and those
that are working
they're kind of afraid to do their job
because they know they won't get support
from their leaders their elected
officials and can you believe it
oh what a shock as a result violent
crime is now spiking
in all of these cities it's so bad that
some democrats
are trying to pretend that it's
republicans that are responsible
for the deep fund of the police movement
others are just
doubling down on their deep fun dreams
take a look
their answer to that question is we must
eliminate funding
for cpb ice and their parent
organization dhs
time after time we have seen it as
advocates on the
ground as human services agency on
ground to continue
to see over and over again that these
agencies are inept
defund the department of homeland
security i ask all of america tonight
have you forgotten have you forgotten
911
have you forgotten radical islamic
terrorists what they did that day
according to the radical socialist
democrats we just stop enforcing
laws at the southern border this crisis
will magically end
can they really be that dumb and that
radical
and many illegal immigrants guess what
they're testing positive at a very high
rate for covid
so we have open borders overcrowded
cages that biden and harris have built
in the middle of a pandemic
and then they're giving them free
transportation to states all across the
country
and by the way the crisis at the border
is yet another unresolved disaster
and that's only getting worse without a
doubt this administration
is an absolute well we'll honor the
great adam schiff
it's a shift show whoever's in charge at
1600 pennsylvania avenue whoever you are
you're doing a pretty terrible job and
tonight the american people
are suffering on all levels tonight as a
result
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else